bonsoir l'assemblée nationale a levé
l'immunité parlementaire de bernard
tapie de vote ôte eu lieu ce soir
le premier sur le dossier d'abus de
biens sociaux le second sur un dossier
de fraude fiscale dans le cadre de la
sphère du fossé à l'union de son bateau
dans les deux cas l'assemblée a voté à
une écrasante majorité plus de 60 460
voix en faveur de la levée de l'immunité
distance
sachez aussi que nous parlerons de la
lutte contre l'exclusion avec notre
invité martine aubry qui a créé il ya
huit mois une fondation avec des
dirigeants d'entreprise bonsoir mais
rendons nous tout de suite à l'assemblée
nationale avait que romain sicard et
pierre laurin constante entre bernard
tapie et les socialistes bernard tapie
n'est pas très content les socialistes
ont décidé de ne pas participer au vote
donc de ne pas le soutenir activement
dialogue ali damman j'aurais préféré non
mais tu veux pas être instrumentalisé
l'affairé en restera là bernard tapie ne
veut plus polémique
il faut dire que dès le départ les
choses semblaient plutôt mal engagé
petit retour en arrière avant même que
la séance ait commencé les dés
semblaient jetés et ce n'est pas du côté
du parti socialiste peut le patron de
l'om comptait ses plus farouches
adversaires
la preuve
mon sentiment est qu'il ya une immense
majorité à l'un des repaires favorable à
la levée
le député est un justiciable comme les
autres
en conséquence la levée d'immunité
parlementaire tient à la teneur du
dossier et nous devons cette immunité
parlementaire aujourd'hui dans ces
conditions bernard tapie n'avait pas
grand chose à espérer alors il a contre
attaqué donc le gouvernement dont il
voit des membres mêlé à des affaires
contre le ps dont l'attitude ne lui
paraît pas clair et surtout contre
l'acharnement politique dont ils
s'estiment victimes d'un deux jours
notre session ordinaire sera terminé et
le juge aura loisir de m'entendre sans
l'autre près condamnation car je ne
souhaiterais pas à son habitation
que signifie cette précipitation il faut
continuer le lynchage de celui dont le
résultat dérange bouleverse une
distribution politique qui était
tellement bien qu aller vers une
élection présidentielle sans surprise
sans surprise non plus le résultat du
vote d'aujourd'hui majorité écrasante
pour la levée de l'immunité
parlementaire de bernard tapie seuls dix
députés ont voté contre
mais à vrai dire le patron de l'om s'y
attendait alors relancé car vous êtes en
direct à l'assemblée nationale que va
faire bernard tapie que peut-il faire
écouter bernard tapie en fait une
tactique simple que ce soit en football
ou en politique il pratique la contre
attaque en usant du contre-pied premier
contre-pied c'était ce matin tout le
monde s'attendait à ce qu'il démissionne
de son poste de député ce qui lui aurait
permis d'éviter le débat qu de cet
après-midi et bien non seulement il n'a
pas démissionné mais il a déposé une
proposition de loi sur un sujet qui lui
tient particulièrement à coeur
le chômage des jeunes qu'il veut rendre
illégal et puis deuxième contre attaque
cette fois sur le plan juridique
bernard tapie a donc perdu son immunité
parlementaire française mais il est
aussi député européen et c'est là que la
polémique 100 verges parce que pour
certains cette immunité ne commence que
le 19 juillet date où se réunira le
parlement strasbourg pour bernard tapie
et bien cette immunité elle a déjà
commencé
c'était le 12 juin lors de l'élection
européenne autrement dit et bien de
rebondissement en rebondissement de
contre-attaquants contre-pied le
feuilleton continue et il s'annonce
plein de surprises merci et roland sicav
martine aubry vous êtes notre invité
pour parler de l'exclusion nous parlera
tout à l'heure mais quel est votre
sentiment sur la levée de l'immunité
si vous voulez je crois qu'il faut que
la justice fasse son travail c'est
évident mais
je ne suis pas sûr qu à deux jours de la
fin de la session parlementaire il n'y
avait pas autre chose de plus utile à
faire à l'assemblée nationale
c'est la seule question je m'oppose qui
a tué ou fait tuer l'ancien président du
rwanda il n'y a pas de réponse pour
l'instant à ce mystère mais l homme
affirme la connaître le capitaine paul
barril accuse le front patriotique
rwandais il a dit clairement dans notre
journal de 13h et l'ancien commandant du
gign a montré pour le démontrer la boîte
noire de l'avion présidentiel a battu
par domicile l'accusation est si grave
qu'elle méritait une enquête sur cette
enquête
car le common patrice pollet le ce qui a
été présenté et donne un des éléments
qu'on a récupéré sur casque
appartiennent à la carcasse de l'avion
et les numéros de série dessus montrent
que ça appartient bien au falcon 50 je
suis pas un spécialiste en aéronautique
chasser un désagrément que il est 13
heures en direct sur france 2 paul baril
nous explique qu'il a récupéré la boîte
noire du falcon 50 du président rwandais
avec sa firme utile ou pourra prouver
que l'avion a été victime d'un tir
missiles une opération soigneusement
préparé
au même instant à toulouse un pilote
philippe landerberg qui regarde france 2
fait un bon pour lui l'objet présenté
par baril n'a rien à voir avec un
enregistreur de vol
une boîte noire tels que monsieur bart
il aurait dû la trouver c'est ça c'est
orange pour commencer internationalement
et ce enregistre tous les paramètres de
l'avion et il a raison ce qu'a présenté
paul barril
c'est un boîtier d'antennes radio compas
sur le falcon 50 il y en a deux le radio
compas oméga sert à aller d'un point à
un autre
entre deux balises l'avion gare de son
cas c'est un appareil inerte qui ne
contient aucune information
une polémique qui présentent au moins un
mérite celui de faire ressurgir la
question essentielle même si personne ne
semble décidé à en trouver la réponse
qui sont les commanditaires de
l'attentât et qui a tiré les deux
roquettes qui ont abattu l'avion du
président rwandais
les mots sont lancés on parle de complot
et même de mercenaires l'ancien membre
de la cellule antiterroriste de l'elysée
a là encore sa version des faits aux
terroristes du fpr qui représentent
seulement 10% de la population
ces gens là ne pourront jamais avoir le
pouvoir au rwanda au moins par les urnes
un homme une voix comme en afrique du
sud une thèse qui va à l'encontre des
enquêtes publiées jusque là et que
rejette évidemment le fpr il faut savoir
d'abord qui est crédit vous donnez aux
et aux déclarations des caps tm et
barredo et il faut d'abord savoir qui il
est si l'ama la terre et sur quelles
bases et travail
dernière interrogation le silence
observé par le gouvernement français
dans cette affaire silence pesant
alors que trois français les trois
membres d'équipage de l'avion du
président rwandais ont eux aussi été tué
dans l'attentât
sur le terrain c'est à dire au rwanda
l'urgence aujourd'hui consistent à
évacuer le maximum de civils l'armée
française s'y emploient 35 religieuse de
diverses nationalités et vite orphelines
ont pu ainsi quitté le couvent de qui
bouillent et où elle s'était réfugiée
reportage de benoît duquesne et eric
mézil
le militaire des marteaux missions
humanitaires ou pas ces hélicoptères qui
survolent le lac kivu frontière
naturelle du zaïre et du rwanda savent
qu'ils sont attendus pour effectuer leur
première mission d'évacuation
d'importance au rwanda ces 40 religieuse
de qui bouillait ont décidé de partir
elles sont américaines anglaises bells
rwandaise
elles ont d'abord fui les massacres de
kigali pour se réfugier dans ce couvent
au bord du lac
mais les visites des milices locales ont
continué interdiction d'héberger des
tutsis intimidations raquette menaces de
mort aujourd'hui elle parle mais battre
en ce moment il faut dire que la
situation reste tendue à quibou y ait
des accrochages ont encore eu lieu hier
à une dizaine de kilomètres de la ville
et une vingtaine d'enfants ont été
retrouvés morts il ya quelques jours à
qui se vaut
parmi les évacués benoît un petit tout
si le seul que les soeurs avaient
hébergé en cachette il parle lui aussi
son amie marie une hutu qui l'avait
prise en charge est resté seul à qui
bouillait françois léotard doit quitter
paris ce soir pour le rwanda le ministre
de la défense va rendre visite demain
aux 2500 soldats français qui
participent à l'opération turquoise et
il rencontrera peut-être un compatriote
qui vit au rwanda qui a été menacé de
mort par les milices et que nos envoyés
spéciaux valérie fournit aux emprunts
soient hoffman oran on retrouvait c'est
une exclusivité poste frontière du
rwanda
l'incursion française n'est pas une
simple patrouille
m de la 11ème dp ont pour mission de
secourir un ressortissant français
menacés de mort d'après nos propres
informations
nous les guidons jusqu'à lui dans les
faubourgs de génie nous l'avons
rencontré quelques heures plus tôt
monterrey depuis deux mois dans sa villa
garder uniquement par deux gendarmes et
rwandais le gendarme il est parti
discrètement les quatre véhicules du
convoi prennent possession des lieux et
le capitaine courtois se dirige vers le
sol français restés dans la ville à ce
seul seulement c'est donc ça le rassure
et me lance ou coup les gens ici disent
que
mais français sont venus pour sauver les
tutsis puis le français qui a aiguisé ni
on s'intéresse pas lu ans pour ça qu'on
est dans la guerre lasse convient je
vous rassure jour met strasbourg depuis
une semaine
alain savait que les militaires français
étaient là juste de l'autre côté de la
frontière à seulement 500 mètres de lui
mais il ne pouvait pas sortir de sa
villa pour les prévenir de sa présence
les milices leurs recherches pour nous
tuer que j'étais bien elle moi je veux
récupérer medien et bien qu'on m'a
appris on nous a tous 16 propriétés et
pourquoi vous repousse soit enfermé
depuis depuis un mois mais parce que
avec les barrages des miliciens il ya
des barrages on nous laisse passer la
dose qui sont agressifs sud veulent pas
de français alors vous fait sortir de la
voiture et puis en rue puisque le goût
de vous tirer dessus c'est pour ça
est-ce que vous auriez dit trop de
choses aussi basiques
enfin je n'oublierai jamais ce que j'ai
vu de toute façon comment vous sentiez
en ce moment ça doit être stressante
voilà je vais craquer d'un jour à
l'autre la sueur témoins des massacres
ce qu'il a vu ne peut pas nous en parler
face caméra craignant encore pour sa vie
tant que les français n'auront pas
organiser sa sécurité
la mission à toi ici c'est d'assurer la
garde
il s'agit bien de la protection c'est à
dire qu'ici on vient voir
le français qui pour nous résume
territoire rwandais
alain tient à rester agité ni pour
récupérer ses biens volés
une ville où dix mille tutsi ont été
tuées en une semaine et il est le seul
occidental à pouvoir en témoigner
le raid auquel vous êtes en direct du
rwanda de bukavu on va revenir avec vous
sur le sort des populations civiles il
faut savoir que des milliers des
milliers de hutus airs de village en
village
oui tout à fait vous savez c'est le
principal problème en tout cas le
problème humanitaire qui risque de se
poser ici on savait par le cca par la
croix rouge qu'il y avait dans le
diocèse de gikongoro c'est environ dans
le centre de de ce qui reste de cette
partie du rwanda a tenu par les forces
gouvernementales que dans ce diocèse
d'après la croix-rouge et ré environ 250
à 500 milles au tout qui fuyaient la
vente du front patriotique rwandais et
bien les militaires français en ont eu
la confirmation aujourd'hui
effectivement une masse de population
énorme qui errent dans cette région là
c'est la conséquence bien sûr de
l'avancée de la guerre mais ces gens là
n'ont absolument aucun soutien pour
l'instant les comptes sont pas organisés
il n'y a pas d'aidé humanitaire il n'y a
pas de nourriture il n'y a absolument
rien et pas demain parce que il ya la
visite de françois léotard mais sans
doute après demain les militaires
français se rendront sur place et il y a
déjà une association humanitaire care
qui a décidé de se rendre avec
éventuellement sur place ou en tout cas
d' organiser très rapidement des convois
pour venir au secours de ces populations
là merci benoît un photographe de
l'agencé américaine associateurs presse
a été blessé aujourd'hui à kigali
ricardo mazagan de nationalité argentine
se trouvait dans sa chambre d'hôtel
quand il va l'a atteint à la jambe
droite
les médecins sont optimistes cela montre
bien les risques du devoir d'informer et
du devoir de secourir les soldats de
l'opération turquoise tout en veillant à
respecter leurs missions humanitaires
restent vigilants isabelle steiss et
pascal pons se sont rendus auprès de
position françaises qui ont entendu hier
l'écho d'affrontements très proche entre
le front patriotique et les
gouvernementaux des commandos-marine
très très vigilants ils surveillent les
collines à quelques qui
home est des hommes du fpr ils sont
positionnés on parle de 1000 à 2000
rebelles
nous sommes la guiche ita ou un evra
logique de l'opération turquoise
car c'est ici que les rebelles petit
serait le plus avancé en territoire
40 commandos marines sont en alerte
au loin des tirs résonnent ça vient
d'entendre musique des bruits d'une arme
automatique lourde
c'est à trois kilomètres d'ici à vol
d'oiseau 3 km les accrochages des plus
violents ont eu lieu hier soir va
m'empêcher les rebelles 3 de l'autre
côté on a entendu un petit peu de bruit
on a vu de la fumée et c'était quel
genre d'affrontement dans des
affrontements qui prend très important
je pense relativement important surtout
à l'échelle du pays
infiltration accrochage exactions de
chaque nuit dans ce secteur
particulièrement sensible
la chasse à l'homme continue un peu
partout les traces des massacres comme
ces charniers à proximité des maisons
détruites toujours proximité de maisons
démolies comme ça on en trouve à 12 ans
c'est l'odeur qui nous guide non c'est
pas récente
à moi ni à peu près
je comptais massacrés dans le coin ont
dû être il y en ait dans des fosses
communes
parce qu'ils ont dû faire deux galeries
qu'on fait il rejetait la terre ici ou
et empiler les décors loin des discours
de bienvenue qui les ont accueillis à
leur arrivée les militaires français se
retrouve maintenant face aux réalités de
la guerre qui déchire le rwanda avec
l'avancée des rebelles
ils ne sont pas loin d'être en première
ligne en france les dirigeants du rpr se
sont montrés étrangement silencieux
aujourd'hui après l'intervention hier
soir sur france 2 du premier ministre
les parlementaires père avait prévu de
se retrouver ce soir à paris de recevoir
la visite d'edouard balladur
ça tombait bien retrouvons jean baptiste
près dali et bernard puis ce soit la
maison de la chimie
ça marche
je veux laver ma vie
les mains
l'intérêt
comment vous allez trouver de faille
ministre hier soir l'acquisition tel
qu'en lui-même trouvé assez bien bien
et là je n'étais pas comment c'est sans
doute la fin de la session il reste
prudent
ils sont aussi au lit avec le premier
ministre
en retard lui du fait de ses obligations
et puis avec une heure de décalage
il ya même eu une rencontre larron que
tout le monde attendait et on va
retrouver jean michel lecarpentier en
direct de la maison de la chimie on a
entendu tout à l'heure un technicien de
dire ça marche ça marche puisque on va
vous voir jean-michel il ya des silences
révélateurs sont apparus dans ce
reportage de près d'al hilal à la
rencontre qu'on attendait et qu'on
appelle le temps de voir là c'était
celle de de jacques chirac et d'edouard
balladur mais au-delà de ça il n'ya pas
encore très longtemps lorsque le premier
ministre parlait le rpr se fendait au
moins d'un communiqué de soutien plus ou
moins chaleureux d'ailleurs mais enfin
des semblants et aujourd'hui selon un
haut dirigeant du mouvement que je cite
personne n'a eu le temps de faire tous
pris par la préparation des municipales
or les élections municipales la valeur
de l'excusent et il est très difficile
ici de trouver un responsable rpr pour
réagir de façon un peu enthousiaste aux
propos d'edouard balladur
hier soir sur notre antenne alors
pourquoi cela bien parce que les cadres
et les élus du mouvement ont compris que
le premier ministre et jacques chirac
sont en compétition directe l'un contre
l'autre et que les deux hommes se
retrouvent un petit peu comme des
coureurs cyclistes qui juste avant le
sprint final font du sur place pour
essayer de laisser partir l'autre et de
mieux le contrôler alors le démarrage de
la course est prévue pour l'automne ou
plus vraisemblablement pour le début
d'année prochaine mais on comprend que
dans ces conditions tout le monde reste
un petit peu prudent et que tout se
fasse dans la discrétion
merci jean michel le ciel quelques
hésitations dans la diffusion du
reportage c'est que la réunion vient de
commencer mais l'image de la rencontre
on l'aura j'espère dans le dernier
journal
absolument merci ce qu'on retiendra
essentiellement des propos d'edouard
balladur
c'est son espoir d'inverser la courbe du
chômage dans les six mois qui viennent
est ce possible
l'enquète de léo lamberton et frédéric
rostaing
espérez toujours espérer en matière de
chômage et beurre balladur ne promet pas
souhaite déjà il ya un nom lors de son
discours d'investiture à l'assemblée
nationale le premier ministre fait cet
aveu qui ainsi que je l' ai déjà dit
progrès sera inéluctablement cette année
soit stabilisée à la fin de 1993 et
qu'une décrue puisse être ensuite amorcé
espoirs d'issue depuis ce nom le chômage
ne s'est pas stabilisé
mois après mois il ne cesse de
progresser mais edouard balladur ne
s'avouent pas vaincus un an plus tard il
continue toujours à espérer la pente sur
l'année sera une diminution à mon avis
considérables qui nous permettra je
l'espère de stopper la croissance du
chômage dans les six mois je l'espère
certes cette année les choses semblent
mieux amorcer la croissance s'annonce
meilleure que prévu on parle de 1,10
pour 194 tous les experts sont d'accord
sur le chiffre n'est pas sur ses
répercussions en matière de chômage
en effet les perspectives de reprise
sont plus forte qu'anticipée de sorte
que le chômage s'aggraverait beaucoup
moins en 1994 qu'il ne l'a fait en 1993
pour vraiment obtenir une stabilisation
du chômage ou un reflux du chômage il
faudrait une croissance qui soit de
l'ordre de 3% plus que cela et c'est
difficile d'attendre sa avant second
semestre 95 ou l'année 96 alors edouard
balladur peut-il raisonnablement espérer
une stabilisation voire une décrue du
chômage dans les six prochains mois
personne ne peut le dire avec certitude
mais tous sont d'accord sur un point
l'espoir permet au moins d'avancer alors
des crues ou pas et la question
s'adresse à martine aubry
ancien ministre du travail quel votre
avis je crois qu'il serait d'abord temps
effectivement que le chômage décroît je
crois qu'il faut se rappeler que le
chômage s'est accru de 340000 depuis que
monsieur balladur est au pouvoir en un
an soit trois fois plus que l'année
dernière donc si ça commence à les
croire ça ne sera pas un exploit
ce sera là la conséquence de la
croissance et je regrette d'ailleurs que
le gouvernement ne l'ait pas accompagné
lots contraire ralenti en prélevant 80
yaro ménages pour les transférer aux
entreprises l'augmentation du chômage
explique en grande partie l'augmentation
d'un fléau qu'on appelle l'exclusion
vous avez créé avec plusieurs dirigeants
d'entreprises une fondation pour lutter
contre ce mal d'exclusion pour tenter de
mettre en relation ceux qui cherchent du
travail avec ce qui pourrait offrir
avant d'en parler
illustration avec dylan chenu et claude
sicard dans un quartier difficile de
marseille c'était l'école maternelle de
la cité de bassens faute d'élèves à la
ferme et il y a deux ans depuis elle a
été minutieusement cassées et pillées
rania vient régulièrement ici elle ya
donné des cours aux enfants de la cité
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus que des
gravats son rêve son projet serait
d'aménager un restaurant et un espace
pour les habitants on peut pas on peut
pas vivre dans un quartier par ailleurs
des accords croisés il faut il faut
refaire au visage endroit absolument le
faire sinon c'est sinon c'est que le
mouroir aflao quoi on va tous mourir
cette cité de bassens et toutes ces vies
elle ya grandi avec ses dix frères et
soeurs rania est à la fois une exception
est un exemple dans sa famille sur le
mur d'entrée tronçon diplôme du
baccalauréat et sa maîtrise de gestion
est pourtant toujours pas de travail
plus de 200 curriculum envoyée et à
chaque fois la même réponse
elle habite à bassens et un quartier
c'est pas trés parce que c'est vraiment
pénalisant d'habiter ici
de ce côté-ci à bassens il ya plus de
80% d'inactifs de l'autre côté de cette
voie rapide une zone industrielle
lentement une passerelle commence à se
matérialiser entre ces deux mondes deux
jeunes diplômés viennent d'être
embauchés dans cette entreprise qui
fournit des repas pour les cantines on
s'intéresse aussi aux diplômes de rania
et à son projet de restaurant mon métier
les jours consiste à restaurer quinze
mille enfants
qu'ils appartiennent à une quarantaine
de populations différentes donc ça me
permet en intégrant des jeunes diplômés
de toutes origines d'être véritablement
dans l'adéquation de ce qu'attendent nos
convives par rapport à notre métier est
un métier de service depuis cinq ans à
marseille la fondation a réussi à lancer
ainsi quelques ponts entre des
entreprises et des cités l'époux ou
encore très fragile et qui demande à
chaque fois la force d'une volonté
économique et politique
alors martine aubry et vous est ce soir
sur un plateau de télévision vous étiez
un peu plus d'un an dans un bureau
ministériel vous avez décidé depuis
qu'une api ministre d'aller sur le
terrain il va y fonder cette fondation
vous avez créé il ya huit mois
est ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui un
premier bilan qu'est ce que vous avez vu
oui tout d'abord de ce qu'on a vu c'est
à dire quand on a lancé cette fondation
c'était ave nuit avec une idée très
claire que l'exclusion était importante
dans notre pays qu'elles s'accroissent
et qu'aucune villes moyennes ou grandes
les n'était à l'abri avait d'ailleurs
des quartiers difficiles avec son
cortège de difficultés de solitude
d'isolement de délinquance de drogue
alors huit mois après avoir été sur six
quartiers que nous avons choisi je
dirais que nous considérons que la
situation aujourd'hui il est peut-être
encore plus noir qu'on le pensait moi je
suis très très frappé par exemple de
voir des jeunes des enfants qui ont des
troubles profonds du comportement de la
personnalité qui aujourd'hui n'arrive
pas à se socialiser et même à exister
je suis frappé aussi de voir que tous
ceux qui devraient agir
les acteurs administratifs traditionnels
les associations qui se battent sont
aujourd'hui très découragés car elles ne
se sentent pas portées par ce projet
donc la situation est vraiment noir vous
êtes socialiste vous mettez pas
forcément en cause la majorité actuelle
mobilité l'excusé s'accroissent c'est un
problème qui plus est un problème qui
s'adresse à toute la société adresse à
toute la société
mais le bilan il est aussi contrastée il
est aussi en teintes roses dans ces
quartiers il y a aussi beaucoup de gens
qui se battent pour s'en sortir on en a
vu là il y à des femmes qui est celle de
sortir des jeunes de la drogue
il ya des femmes qui organisent du
soutien scolaire gilles ya des femmes
parce que c'est souvent des femmes il ya
des habitants qui sont prêts à saisir la
moindre opportunité qu'on leur propose
pour sortir de la situation dans
laquelle m dans un premier temps on a
pensé que la lutte contre l'exclusion
passer par des activités ludiques ou
sportives ou culturelles
et là vous voulez vraiment impliquer les
entreprises
les informations avec des entreprises et
c'est d'ailleurs le deuxième aspect
important
il y avait des entreprises derrière nous
pour travailler sur l'exclusion mais je
dois dire que moi même je ne pensais pas
qu'elles seraient autant impliqué dans
la réflexion et surtout dans l'action
car dans ces quartiers ce que demandent
les habitants ce n'est pas de la
sollicitude ce n'est pas des discours ce
n'est pas de l'argent
il demande de retrouver la dignité par
l'emploi et par le travail et nous
l'avons vu là avec quelques exemples à
marseille de ce que nous faisons un
certain nombre d'entreprises qui sont
avec nous ont embauché des uns déjà des
habitants du quartier soit pour réaliser
des tâches classiques poser des portes
blindées rénover les immeubles alors que
leurs salariés ne veulent plus
travailler dans ces quartiers soit pour
se réimplanter dans ces quartiers et
c'est vrai par exemple d'entreprise de
distribution ou du club méditerranée qui
embauchait des jeunes des quartiers pour
pour cet été parmi ces dirigeants
d'entreprise qui vous êtes
il ya des dirigeants de diverses
sensibilités politiques au tout à fait
et d'ailleurs nous travaillons dans des
quartiers dont les élus sont très divers
mais je crois que nous avons tous une
volonté commune c'est de faire en sorte
de faire connaître cette situation
d'exclusion et que notre société dans
toutes ses entrées s'en préoccupent et
se demande ce qu'elle peut faire
question a pris une autre question elle
est par exemple à amiens et vous avez
travaillé avec le maire udf damien vidal
revient tout à doc là vous dépasser les
clivages
est ce que vous n'avez pas le sentiment
qu actuellement dans le milieu politique
il ya deux tons de discours de
comportement un comportement un peu
populiste de démagogique et à l'autre
comportement plus pragmatique mais plus
difficile à faire passer auprès de
l'opinion
écoutez moi je crois que quand on est
sur le terrain en tout cas moi quand je
le suis que je sois dans une commune qui
a un maire communiste socialiste
edf ou européenne à partir du moment où
on veut agir on agit ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on est d'accord sur tout je suis par
exemple totalement d'accord avec gilles
de robien lorsqu'il dit il va falloir
dégager des dizaines de milliards de
francs pour reconstruire des villes à la
place de ces quartiers ghettos mais je
ne suis pas sûr d'être d'accord sur tout
avec lui sur les réformes fiscales qui
seront nécessaires pour pouvoir moins
pénaliser l'emploi et développer celui
ci dans notre pays mais je dirais que ce
n'est pas grave nous travaillons à la
recherche de solutions et puis ensuite
chacun avec ses convictions et ses
valeurs construira un projet qui
j'espère améliorer la situation des
français
c'est ça la politique ces clivages vont
réapparaître cela peut paraître insolite
mais c'est ainsi c'est la vie politique
à l'occasion
présidentielle ce sera ma seule question
politique enfin une expression c'est
saku le papa pourra-t-il écouté les vues
comme vous à la télévision retour de
corfou il a l'air en bonne forme je vais
le voir dans quelques jours je vous
donnerai des nouvelles
jacques delors très sollicitée pour se
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
quel est votre avis va le faire ou pas
ok je crois que lui seul peut il répond
je ne me permettrais pas de le faire à
sa place vous savez que si le papa ne
fait pas beaucoup pensent à la fille ça
ce sont des gens qui ont beaucoup
d'humour
dominique strauss kahn par exemple mais
oui chacun 6 à 10 en sommes là pourquoi
pas martine aubry ça aurait de la gueule
calculer votre avis écoutez je pense que
quand on pense à des femmes ont subi de
temps en temps ça serait des plantes
vertes ça changerait le paysage alors
moi j'espère que un jour j'aurai des
responsabilités politiques pour faire
bouger les choses pour faire changer la
société en tout cas j'y travaille merci
martine aubry l'avion ça vole le train
ça roule l'avion et le train en principe
ne devrait jamais se rencontrer mais il
ya des principes que les architectes ne
veulent pas connaître ils ont créé à
lyon cette line superbe cathédrale
inaugurée aujourd'hui par le premier
ministre est destinée précisément à
favoriser la rencontre impossible
visite guidée avec antoine cormery alain
du bas voici le prototype de la gare du
21e siècle une gare tgv à l'architecturé
futuriste imaginée par l'espagnol
santiago calatrava une cathédrale
d'aluminium et de verre tellement belle
qu'on vient de loin pour la visiter
j'avais des pâtés par l'aérodrome de
singapour mais 100 fois mieux
mais cette gare de lyon satolas n'est
pas une gare comme les autres les
spécialistes appellent même sa une
plateforme multimodale plateforme
multimodale et alliant les trois modes
de trafic
l'avion cette plateforme multimodale
donc qui doit faire concurrence à genève
est installé à porter tapis roulant de
l'aéroport sur le nouveau tracé tgv
contournaient lyon par l'est et permet
de gagner une demi heure entre paris et
valence la gare est né de la volonté du
conseil général et du conseil régional
qui l'ont financé à hauteur de 75% sur
une facture totale de 990 millions
mais pour les écologistes notamment
cette gare est une coquille vide
la liaison ferroviaire vers lyon n'est
pour l'instant qu'un projet et le rythme
des tgv est bien maigrichon mais
lorsqu'un homme politique ou un
responsable de collectivité
construits
une réalisation on l'accuse vote à faire
trop car je sois d'un 4e tour je préfère
être accusé d'avoir fait trop tôt jara
pas dès ce moment là on peut faire une
programmation pour l'avenir et manqué en
puissance et l'avenir c'est l'horizon
2010 lorsque les réseaux tgv vers
l'italie l'espagne et le nord seront
plus développés alors seulement la gare
de cette classe pourra rayonner sur
l'europe
48 heures après les inondations dans les
alpes maritimes la même question se pose
sempiternel comme à vaison-la-romaine
pourquoi la catastrophe s'est elle
produite la fatalité tel seul en cause
mais les réponses varient
il y à des villages qui n'avaient rien
prévu il ya des villages qui avaient
pris leurs précautions reportage de
claude son père éric de lannion
l'impuissance et la fatigue
le petit village d'auribeau se remet
aujourd'hui difficilement du terrible
orage de dimanche
toutes les habitations en bord de
rivière ont été dévastés vous avez été
envoyés chez kingston
c'est mon outil de travail qui sont
j'ai hésité un peu tôt de du coin j'ai
plus rien comprendre
le désespoir et les questions comment
expliquer que l'on ait construit encore
tout récemment en pleine zone inondable
pour les autorités le maire en tête
on ne peut rien faire contre la fatalité
ensuivie une catastrophe qui est
totalement imprévisible même même
d'arles et les gens qui se mettait dans
les conditions les plus pessimistes ne
pouvait pas prévoir une telle
catastrophe
dans d'autres communes du même
département les élus on fume habitudes
tout à fait différente
exemple le village de gattières en
bordure du bar en 1981 toute la partie
basse de la ville a été noyée sous les
eaux continuent à arriver par la
nouvelle caserne la normale à bout
avaient fait glisser une partie de la
colline et jeunes oliviers qui avait
glissé cathédrale portail tout vous
depuis la commune est établie toute une
série de canaux pour l'écoulement des
eaux ou total 3 millions prend il faut
réaliser des ouvrages qui évite aux
biens et aux personnes d'être touchées
par des phénomènes c'est vrai assez
exceptionnel mais disons que nous sommes
confrontés de plus en plus à ces
phénomènes donc exceptionnalité devient
quelque chose de moins juste un maire
qui prend en considération les risques
d'inondations un maire qui résistent aux
pressions immobilière il y en a
malheureusement peu sur les 8500 commune
qui présentent des risques d'inondations
en france seulement 625 ont pris des
mesures concrètes et l'on n'ouvre la
rubrique sportive avec de retour
spectaculaire le premier du britannique
nigel mansell il revient à la formule 1
il va piloter la williams renault il a
même testé cet après midi sur le circuit
de brands hatch en grande bretagne et il
est satisfait elle est conforme à mes
attentes at il dit et même un peu mieux
les disputera dimanche le grand prix de
france sur le circuit de nevers magny
cours
on va rester justement en grande
bretagne avec l' autre retour celui du
français guy forget qui est actuellement
1100 30e joueur mondial et qui s'est
qualifié pour les quarts de finale à
wimbledon françois brabant 9 heures du
soir à londres ça fait 10 ans du soir à
paris bref ça fait tard pour jouer au
tennis à wimbledon
on y voit plus grand chose sur les
courts d'un côté tout le monde a fini de
jouer tout le monde sauf dit forget les
organisateurs n'attendent plus que lui
pour fermer allez on se dépêche
et voilà le travail
5 1 dans le quatrième set dit forget va
pouvoir finir avant la nuit
jeremy bex l'anglais n'est pas si
pressée le public britannique aimerait
bien que ça dure un petit peu plus aussi
mais s'est forgé qui m'a servi
et le miracle continue forgé n'était
plus rien il est en quarts de finale à
wimbledon et beaucoup de choses soudain
la nuque par hasard aujourd'hui alors
que alors que j'ai gagné quatre matches
mais bon ça wimbledon
j'ai ressenti une façon braqués sur moi
je reçois des files étaient les g des
tutsis je reprends du service donc lâché
un petit peu marre en mai
alors que je suis pas je suis pas plus
intelligent ne manquait à moi plus
intelligent peut-être pas plus heureux
ça s'est su et l'on passe à la coupe du
monde de football avec une terrible
déception pour l'italie qui a fait match
nul contre le mexique 1 partout le
mexique s'est qualifié l'italie devra
attendre pour savoir si elle se qualifie
pour le prochain tour thierry clopeau le
premier but il est italien et un début
de deuxième mi-temps du réalisateur
america est endormi et c'est massaro sur
une face baggio qui bat le petit gardien
mixité 1 campos italie est alors
qualifié la seule tenue de latex for
speed
58e minute de jeu réaction d'orgueil des
mexique a et c permal décalé qui ne
laisse aucune chance au vol de la fois
drg a jouera lors final 1 partout
le médecin était qualifié pour les
huitièmes de finale les italiens eux
sont pratiquement éliminés
il leur faudra attendre ce soir le
résultat d'air norvège
et si vous aimez le foot vous aimez
forcément le cameroun alors prévoyez un
bon café ce soir pour suivre le match
que le cameroun jouera contre la russie
patrice ce romdhane a suivi
l'entraînement de nos amis
oui
les rugissements d'henri michel
suffiront ils à réveiller les lions
indomptables contre la russie mystère
ces jours ci l'équipe du cameroun s'est
entraîné à dose homéopathique une heure
quotidienne
au delà le soleil et puis l'organisme
après la défaite contre le brésil 3 0
deux impératifs d'abord peaufiner la
récupération ensuite réparer les dégâts
psychologiques
je crois qu'il faut avoir référence au
match contre la suède où elle était
capable de revenir au score mais on a
été capable de donner au score
il faut avancer en tête et puis il faut
avoir en tête les petites erreurs qu'on
a fait contre le brésil à savoir reculer
à avoir un petit peu peur donner de
l'espace aux brésiliens et ça c'est
monté c'est ce qui nous est arrivé
le problème c'est que la russie malgré
deux défaites en deux matches se trouve
dans la même situation que le cameroun
ça il faut vraiment se méfier savoir qu'
ils ont aussi une carte à jouer à
l'autruche photo de famille sur fond de
pelouse californienne il ne tient qu'au
cameroun est de faire en sorte que ce ne
soit pas la dernière
ils savent que tous les retient ici à
commencer par l'accueil des américains
et la quiétude de l'université
sainte-marie où il se prépare et dont le
cadre force à croire à espérer
les camerounais doivent battre la russie
s'ils veulent être présents au deuxième
tour de cette coupe du monde dans le cas
contraire
d'aucuns diront que l'épopée de 1990
n'était qu'un feu de paille
et c'est sans doute ce genre de
commentaires qui les affecterait le plus
tintin doit être bien triste l'a déjà
perdu son papa rg en 82 il perd
aujourd'hui son tonton l'éditeur
casterman marielle bono marcel martin
qu'est-ce que ça suggère pour vous
quelle sera ma mission qu'est-ce qu'ils
édictent des gommes bd comme bd les
bains je crois qu'il est temps
c'est à 18h extrêmement important en
bande dessinée ne fût ce que parce que
dans son fond il ya les albums tintin
lui robert casterman c'était lui ici
avec hergé casterman c'est d'abord un
nom connu surtout pour avoir imprimé en
1934 l'album tintin est un talus est
resté fidèle
il représente à lui seul 30% un chiffre
d'affaires de 600 millions de francs
une maison qui édite 2000 titres des
histoires qui privilégie l'image la
moitié de sa production
c'est de la bande dessinée lui robert
casterman a développé des livres pour
enfants comme la série des martine 40
exemplaires dans le monde et il a édité
beaucoup de grands commis ce beau prat
et son aventurier corto maltese ou
encore tardy la grande famille de la bd
est triste d'avoir perdu l'un des siens
une page du grand livre casterman est
tournée les l'histoire continue une
histoire commencée il y à 115 ans en
belgique
et pour conclure vous propose d'écouter
j'ai bien dit écoutez la lettre ouverte
que marie-josée le picard écrit un jeune
ami avec que l'aide de bernard puis
sochaux elle lui parle de nadar comme un
album de famille à feuilleter pour les
élèves de première l'exposition de
photos de nadar on vient découvrir un
pionnier de la photographie on s'arrête
constamment devant des visages familiers
voilà le pauvre charles si grand poète
su mauvaise mine et cb news écoute la
valse fantastique
et alexandre dumas oui oui la reine
margot les trois mousquetaires le comte
de monte cristo les frères goncourt ce
du prix qui sait bien les michelais
l'historien jeanne d'arc l'histoire de
france en dix sept volumes et tu l'as lu
et on aurait donné le caricaturiste tu
vois cet habit noir et ce regard perçant
et c'est la jolie sarah 20 ans à peine
en 1864 mais ton arrière grand mère l'a
vu jouer l'aiglon avant la guerre de 14
que de célébrité mais nadar photographes
amateurs étaient journalistes les
caricaturistes de quoi se faire un joli
cercle de relations
ce qui intéressait nadar au départ
c'était à la suite de son panthéon
lithographier de représenter les grands
hommes de son temps que ce soit des
littéraires que ce soit des musiciens
des hommes de théâtre y en a beaucoup
dans l'exposition des peintres et puis
aussi quelquefois les crocs femme de son
temps comme george sand l'écrivain qui
vouait une véritable adoration visages
connus visage d'un inconnu dont il ne
reste que les prénoms finette maria tous
photographier dans son jardin à la
lumière du jour
portrait n'est pas seulement du juge
dans quelques instants sophie davant de
face vous annoncera le temps pour demain
notamment des orages à nouveau et sans
doute de la pluie dans l'est du pays
20h55 riz droite rive gauche de philippe
labro avec un bouquet de stars depardieu
nathalie baye et carole bouquet 22h52
bas les masques le dernier numéro de la
saison gp2 la saison 2011 du mas minuit
le dernier journal de philippe lefait
demain 13h daniel bilalian je vous
retrouverai demain soir à 20h pour un
nouveau journal bonne soirée sur france
2 bons soins